today on the matt walsh show joe biden's
attorney general nominee claims that
domestic terrorism
doesn't count when it happens at night
we'll talk about that in some of his
other
bizarre statements during his
confirmation hearings plus five
headlines including the head of the
american federation of teachers
arrogantly waving away
concerns about the well-being of
children also coca-cola
continues its damage control efforts
after its racist anti-white
indoctrination of employees was revealed
and in our daily cancellation
we'll discuss a recent study which
claims that left-wing
female politicians are the primary
targets of abuse and harassment online
is there any truth to that no there
isn't but we'll discuss all of that and
more today on the matt welsh show
yesterday joe biden's attorney general
nominee merrick garland began his
confirmation hearings uh biden aims to
give garland the attorney general
position as kind of a runner-up prize
after the senate republicans
famously and correctly chose not to give
him a hearing as a scotus nominee in
2016 a decision that remains one of the
republican party's greatest achievements
of the 21st century which probably tells
you
what you need to know about the
republican party in the 21st century in
any case
garland did get a hearing this time now
normally a confirmation hearing for a
cabinet official
is the last thing that i would waste
time talking about on this show not
because it doesn't matter
but because frankly i find it incredibly
boring this hearing has been no
exception to the incredibly boring rule
though there have been a couple of
clarifying and perhaps instructive
moments to come out of the otherwise
painfully dull spectacle
moments that clarify and and instruct
because
they reveal just what sorts of people we
have ruling over
us and that is hollow people empty
people the sorts of people who c.s lewis
described as
men without chests now before we get to
the two exchanges that capture this so
clearly
i want to play one other brief clip that
was interesting for a different reason
um here garland is talking to cory
booker about the incident
at the capitol on january 6th and i want
to show you i want you to pay attention
to what garland says listen
is this something that you will look at
in terms of the degree of the resources
of the agency
yeah as i said i think the first thing i
should do
as part of the in my briefings on the
capital bombing
are briefings with um director ray as to
where he sees
the biggest threat and whether the
resources of the bureau
and of the department are allocated
towards uh the biggest threat and the
most
uh dangerous and direct threat um we do
have to be careful
across the board we can never uh you
know
let somebody sneak around the end
um because we're not focusing but we
also have to allocate our resources
towards the
biggest threat right the the what now
the capital
bombing you might say this was a slip of
the tongue and maybe so but it does
raise an intriguing question the capital
was not bombed on january 6. nothing was
bond
however there were there were two bombs
placed outside of both the rnc and dnc
headquarters originally we were told
that these bombs were put there
during the chaos during the riots by a
rioter
now we know that it happened the night
before the bombs have always been tied
and by the media are still tied to the
riot
as part of the media's effort to make
the riot sound as insurrectiony
as possible and yes that's a real word i
just decided
but it doesn't seem like they had
anything to do with each other given
that the bombs were put there the night
before so
who did put the bombs there i mean now
that you bring up the bombs
who put them there what was that all
about it's a month and a half later we
still don't know
how can that be someone put bombs
outside rnc and dnc headquarters
in the middle of washington dc there's
been an army of federal agents working
this case
and they still don't know who did it
cameras dna fingerprints witnesses
i mean these lines of evidence have
produced no results how could that be
of course the other possibility is that
they do know who did it but they aren't
published publicizing that fact for
whatever reason anyway that's a bit of a
sidetrack let's go
let's go to a different clip now that
gets closer to the point for our
purposes today here is senator holly
questioning garland about the antifa
slash blm writing
and asking whether those riots qualify
as domestic
terror attacks and here's garland's
answer to that
let me ask you about assaults on
federal property in places other than
washington d.c portland for instance
seattle do you regard assaults on
federal courthouses or other federal
property properties acts of domestic
extremism domestic terrorism well
a senator my own definition which is
about the same as the statutory
definition
is the use of violence or threats of
violence
an attempt to disrupt democratic
processes
so an attack on a
courthouse while in operation trying to
prevent
judges from actually deciding cases that
plainly is
domestic extremism
domestic terrorism an attack simply on a
government property at night or any
other kind of
circumstances is a clear crime and a
serious one and should be punished
i don't mean i don't know enough about
the facts of the example you're talking
about but
that's where i i draw the line one one
is both are
uh criminal um but one is
a core attack on our democratic
institutions um
um uh um um
uh um um uh
wait a second i'm sorry what if i'm
hearing this correctly it sounded like
he just claimed that the definition of
domestic terrorism depends on the time
of day
yes that is what he said isn't it am i
am i hallucinating
or did the the guy who's going to be
attorney general just say that it
doesn't count as domestic terrorism if
you do it at night
i guess this means the 9 11 attacks
wouldn't have been terrorism had they
occurred a few hours
earlier now one might argue
that attempting to for example burn down
a courthouse
at night is also an attempt to interfere
with its normal operations during the
day
i don't think the blm terrorists had in
mind that the courthouse or any other
building that they attempted to torch or
succeeded in torching
would be rebuilt in six hours what about
the police station in minneapolis that
was invaded and then set on fire and
incinerated
yeah that happened at night but there
were police occupying it
and working inside it until they fled
for their lives does that count as
interrupting the democratic process
i'd say that setting a police station on
fire is a bit of an interruption call me
crazy
but this is what we get from guys like
garland bureaucrats you know empty suits
empty heads
they don't even bother to be convincing
he offered the lamest
possible rationalization for exempting
antifa and blm from the domestic
terrorist label
he wasn't even putting effort into it
well no they see they
they're at night so it's different
uh and it doesn't matter because when
you have the institutions on your side
you don't have to lie convincingly
speaking of lame responses nothing can
beat this here's garland
when asked whether males should be
allowed to take part in
female sports here's what he said in my
last 20 seconds i'm going to ask you
if you agree with this statement uh
allowing
and i'm not suggesting the answer one
way or the other i just want to know
what you believe
allowing biological males to compete
in an all-female sport deprives
women of the opportunity to participate
fully and fairly in sports
and is fundamentally unfair to female
athletes
this is a very difficult societal
question that you're asking here i know
what underlies it no but you're going to
be attorney general oh but
i may not be the one who has to make
policy decisions like that but it's not
that i'm adverse to it look i think
every
human being should be treated with
dignity and respect
and that's an overriding sense of my own
character but an overwriting sense of
what the law
requires this the particular
question of how title ix applies in
schools is one and in light of the
bosnica case
which i know you're very familiar with
is something that i would have to look
at
when i have a chance to do that i've not
had the chance to consider these kinds
of issues in my
career so far but i agree that this is a
difficult question
thank you judge no no it's not
it's not a difficult question at all it
is in fact
the easiest question society has ever
faced
i can't think of an easier one there are
some issues that are difficult because
good arguments can be made on either
side of them
even if you fall firmly on one side side
of an issue of that sort the difficult
sort of issue
you still have to admit that the people
on the other side are making respectable
intelligent even compelling arguments
uh the death penalty for example is an
issue that you might call difficult
because there are
respectable intelligent coherent
arguments you can make on either side of
it
those are those are truly difficult
societal questions this question though
is not difficult it's not difficult
because all of the coherent arguments
are on one side
the people in favor of putting males and
female sports or female locker rooms for
that matter
have never made a single good argument
it's not an exaggeration it's not
hyperbole
they've just never made a good argument
there is no good argument it's never
been offered it's never been discovered
they have not offered one compelling
reason to convince us to go along with
their plan their argument is simply to
shout the word bigots
and then rattle off a series of bumper
sticker slogans like you just heard him
there do there well i think all people
should be treated with dignity and
respect
what the hell does that have to do with
this yes of course everyone should be
treated with dignity respect
obviously that has nothing to do with
this question
and if it does have anything to do with
the question then it relates to the fact
that we should treat
women these girls with dignity and
respect by not letting men
boys into their locker rooms
see the the people on that side of it
they have never made an argument that
can be stated that can be stated in the
form of
i believe that x is the proper course of
action for the following reasons
see that that's that's basically the
form that a real argument should take
here's what i believe here are my
reasons for believing it
it's never been done because they're
wrong on every level
morally ethically scientifically
logically this is not difficult
garland may as well say it's difficult
when i ask him whether flying
fire-breathing dragons exist
well the issue of whether these
creatures from fantasy novels exist in
real life is
deeply controversial and far too
difficult to determine one way or
another
um uh i'd really have to
research it further before i can speak
on any length
on this issue but garland perfectly
represents many of our bureaucrats
politicians members of the ruling class
it's not that they're radical ideologues
okay this is something that i think
sometimes people on the right don't
fully understand or
or miss the uh miss the real point now
some of them are radical ideologues sure
but not all or even most they are merely
empty hollow spineless
nothings they have attached themselves
like barnacles onto the system they care
only for power
power for its own sake this gender stuff
is the perfect illustration
how many democratic officials i ask you
how many democratic officials and
politicians
actually believe in left-wing gender
theory
how many guys like garland garland is is
whatever
97 years old he's been he's been doing
this forever
do you think he really believes this do
you think he actually in his heart and
mind
thinks that a 17 year old boy who says
he's a girl should be treated like one
how many guys like garland i'd wager
that answer is the answer that question
is close to zero
but they're happy to go along with the
insanity and facilitate it and impose it
on the rest of us
if it means that they can cling to their
positions of power the best example of
this is the guy at the top joe biden
himself
he's not a radical he's not an ideologue
he's not he's not a an antifa
sympathizer deep in his soul
but he's happy to play that role happy
to let the radicals run roughshod over
our culture inflicting whatever damage
they're going to inflict
it's okay with him because he has the
power
power for its own sake that's all that
these people
care about now let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
speaking of empty pathetic soulless
people the head of the american
federation of teachers randy
weingarten was asked if
shutting schools for a year or more will
do permanent damage
to our children um it's clear that randy
weingarten
isn't too concerned about that that's
already been clear that the
the teachers union doesn't care about
the damage that they're doing to kids
but to hear it so explicitly
acknowledged
can be uh maybe even a little shocking
so let's let's listen to this
is there a point and maybe you think
we've already passed it
is there a point in which kids have been
out of physical in-person school for so
long
that the education that they've lost
isn't really recoverable that that the
third grade the fourth grade the
kindergarten they lost
you can they can take extra semesters in
the summer they can do
but it can't really be fixed no i don't
believe that
i believe that kids are resilient and
kids will recover
but we as adults have to meet their
needs
their emotional needs their social needs
their learning needs
and that's who america's educators are
that's who america's bus drivers are
that's who america's paraprofessionals
are that's who america's food service
workers are
and we are pained about what has
happened in this pandemic
the crises that have enveloped
our kids our communities ourselves
but at the end of the day we have to
believe
that this is recoverable and we have to
believe
that virtually all our kids will thrive
with the opportunities that we put
before them
we have to believe we have to believe it
is it true well it's a different
question entirely but we have to believe
it
what an absolute nothing of a person you
just saw there
she was giving a stump speech this is
she's a teacher's union
um this is the issue that she's been
has been knee-deep in now for a year
and she's asked to talk about the kids
and the effect this is having on kids
and that's all she's got she's got a
stump speech she has nothing to say
it's like she hasn't it's like she
hasn't thought about it at all because
she hasn't because she doesn't care
she's not thinking about what this is
doing to kids she couldn't give less of
a damn
so she gives a stump speech like a
politician giving us campaign speech
that's what our food service
professionals are all about what
what does it have to do with anything
that's who our food service prof
who asked about food service
professionals what are you
talking about i wish just once i'd watch
an interview like this
and the person giving the interview
would would react like that this is why
i don't get that's why i don't get the
interviews
just interrupt her and say hey listen
you're babbling right now
can you can you speak to me like a human
being are you capable of that
now she says that kids are resilient
well kids are resilient they'll be fine
would it would it be okay could i i i
couldn't give that response about
teachers
we can't put teachers back in the class
and say teachers are resilient they'll
figure it out
of course we know that a lot of teachers
are not resilient that much is clear
but this this idea that the kids are
resilient and and so they'll they'll be
okay and
we can take away a year of education or
two years um
and and you know we can psychologically
traumatize them and tell them
that there's a disease out there that's
going to kill them and we have to muzzle
them when they're out in public
and we can do all that we can deprive
them of um not just physical contact
with other people
but even even the the opportunity to see
the faces of strangers out in public
you know a lot of kids they have not
seen a stranger's
face in public in a year
but we can do that because they're
resilient we're told by this
person um
yeah but here's the thing see we say
kids are resilient
they're not resilient so much as
adaptive
okay i don't think resilient is exactly
the right word
because resilient makes it sound like
you could do whatever you want
to a child and they'll bounce back and
be fine that is not true they
they are adaptive though they adapt
very quickly to almost any situation
and that could be a great advantage with
kids you know we're all like that as
kids we kind of need to be like that
especially as children we're going out
into the big wide world we don't really
understa as a young child you don't
really know anything about the world and
so you have to kind of go with the flow
um and so and so
kids kids can do that but there's also a
dark side to that
to that adaptability that
of children is that
whatever's happening to them they'll
accept it as normal they're not going to
question it because they're kids
and they're going to say well this is
just what it's what it's supposed to be
that's why a lot of kids who are being
horribly abused
don't tell anybody because they don't
understand
that this isn't supposed to happen to
them they figure oh mommy and daddy
treat me like this
this is just what mommy and daddies do
this is what this is what it means to be
a person this is what it means to be a
kid
i deserve this this is what kids are
saying to themselves this is why they
don't come forward it's why they it's
why they endure the abuse for so long
and don't tell anybody
um does that mean that they're resilient
they'll just bounce back it's not
affecting them not at all
all it means is that the real effect is
something that that
they're not able to deal with right now
but they're going to be in therapy for
the rest of their lives dealing with it
as adults
i worry about that a lot with what's
happening right now
with all the lockdowns and everything
and schools being shut down
i worry about how adapted our kids are
to it
they simply accept it as normal this is
the world now
education is something that we can take
away for a year it's no big deal
we wear masks when we go out in public
we're afraid to talk to strangers we're
afraid we're afraid to
be around other people it's dangerous to
be on a playground that's why they got
them covered in caution tape
kids adapt to that and they say well
that's that's just how it is that's
normal
it's not normal it's not how it's
supposed to be
but they're being conditioned to see it
that way
and that is doing enormous damage to
them and it's damage
that they won't fully understand
themselves until they're adults
it's damaging them in ways that they
certainly don't understand and we don't
understand
and we won't even begin to understand
until years down the line
that's the reality but i'm saying this
is someone who actually gives a damn
about what happens to our kids the way
the people that are running teachers
unions
they don't care at all about our kids
they're sociopaths all right this is
from newsweek uh coca-cola facing
mounting backlash from conservatives
online
has responded to allegations of
anti-white rhetoric after an internal
whistleblower leaked screenshots of
diversity training materials that
encourages staff to
try to be less white by the way starting
here in the very first sentence you
notice how newsweek says that it's
conservatives who are
the the ones who are causing this
backlash over the anti-white racism for
coca-cola now
that's correct it is mostly
conservatives but you see how
readily the media admits that
conservatives are the only ones who care
about racism against white people the
media will
readily uh accept
in fact is happy to give that issue to
conservatives
on friday back to the articles it says
on friday carolyn
baransenko an activist who supports
banning critical race theory shared
images from an internal whistleblower of
the company's online racism training
the slides include included tips to
learners on how to be
less white less arrogant less certain
less defensive less ignorant and more
humble
because of course we know that you know
that's synonymous with white
is being arrogant and all those other
things
now uh so this is the party you probably
heard about all this a coca-cola
spokesperson confirmed that the course
is
part of a learning plan to help build an
inclusive workforce but also noted that
quote
the video circulating on social media is
from a publicly available linkedin
learning series and is not a focus
of our company's curriculum they said
our better together global learning
curriculum is part of a learning plan to
help build an inclusive workforce
it is comprised of a number of short
vignettes each a few minutes long
the training includes access to linkedin
learning on a variety of topics
including on diversity equity
and inclusion okay so that's uh that's
your classic non-denial
denial um because they're saying
they're not coming out and saying this
is totally made up and photoshopped it's
not real
they're saying yeah this is part of the
curriculum it's just that's not our
focus we're not focused on that part of
it
well if we want to know whether that
excuse should wash then all we have to
do is like i always say
with something like this if you want to
know whether it's racist and if it's not
immediately clear to you like something
like this should be
all you have to do is take white out and
put
another race in so if coca-cola was
putting their employees through a
training course that at any point
included
the instruction to be less black
there would be no controversy at all
this would we we wouldn't be calling
this a controversy there'd be nothing
like that
around just everybody would agree
across all aisles would agree that it's
uh that it's
inexcusable racism and it's racism by
the way
just straightforward racism because the
other thing that i've seen in response
to this um
coca-cola story is uh the claim that
this is reverse racism
in fact there are still some i think
most conservatives have
have wised up on this issue but
there are still some conservatives that
i've seen saying this is reverse racism
coca-cola's committing reverse racism
no this is not reverse racism let's be
clear about that
coca-cola is not guilty of reverse
racism
they are guilty of racism
straightforward
regular old racism there's no such thing
as reverse
racism there's just racism
that that's it reverse racism implies
when you say reverse racism you are
you're surrendering the point you're
seeding ground
you're agreeing with the left's premise
that racism itself is a white
thing and that white white people own
racism and so if a black person or if a
non-white person is racist
they are all they're doing is reversing
the racism
which has a hin the phrase itself has a
hint of kind of
giving them a taste of their own
medicine right
or just we're reversing the racism back
on you
yeah there's no race that owns racism
racism is racism reverse racism is not a
thing
this is simply racism all right um
this is from the independent it says a
south african farm owner has been
strongly criticized after posing with
the heart of a giraffe that she shot and
killed during a trophy hunting
trip earlier this month in a series of
photos posted on um
her facebook page the 32 year old was
shown clutching the bloodied organ
she wrote in the caption ever wondered
how a big dr
how big a giraffe's heart is i'm
absolutely over the moon with my big
valentine's present so she was brought
by her i don't know if it's a husband or
a boyfriend
as a valentine valentine's gift to go
cut shoot a giraffe and cut its heart
out um
no this is everyone has their own ideas
of romance
that's not my wife's idea of romance if
i told her her valentine gift she gets a
cut an animal's heart out she
you know would be very concerned but um
let's see it says in a separate facebook
post she
said she has been waiting to hunt a big
black giraffe bowl since 2016
and was pictured holding a gun next to
the lifeless body of a large giraffe
and then etc and so forth and of course
there's been a huge backlash this was
trending online
um and she's getting i think probably
all of the
the reaction that she expected and i
guess partly wanted that's why she
posted the pictures in the first place
i'm realizing as i read this story that
there's nothing i can say about it that
won't get me in trouble
um i'm i'm not the guy to comment
on any animal rights type issues because
i care so little about those issues
now with trophy hunting from what i
don't know a lot about trophy hunting so
i'll admit that from the start
um one thing i will say is that
if you're going out and killing an
animal
as a trophy and whatever whatever
cutting its head off and mounting on the
wall
and then all all of the the meat and
everything goes to waste
i don't think hunters are doing that but
if that's what's happening i'd be
totally against that
uh my understanding with trophy hunting
is that these animals are
the meat is then given to the villagers
and and so there's there's food provided
and if that's what happens in the case
of trophy hunting if there's food being
provided to people who need it
i got no problem with it as long as it's
not a waste
as long as we're not wasting an animal's
life for no reason other than taking the
picture
i think we all should be against that
but you're harvesting the meat you're
feeding hungry people
human beings who need the food i got no
problem with that
and um and i'm always going to go back
to the fact
anytime there's outrage over an animal
being killed you know
i can't help but uh but think that we
are a country where
a million human babies are murdered
every single year
and i don't see how we have the time to
talk about animals being killed
given that i think whatever
effort or energy anyone is putting into
animal rights all of that should be
directed towards
unborn children who are being
slaughtered 60 million since roe v wade
until we stop that from happening i
don't think we have the time to worry
about any about animals
who are being killed that's that's my
perspective i know you could say we
could do both
yeah but the issue of 60 million babies
being slaughtered
60 million so vastly outweighs
the concerns of animal rights that i
don't see how we can do both
frankly all right uh let's see
nbc news reports an explosive prop being
built for a gender reveal party
accidentally detonated and killed a
father to be in new york state
the tragic mishap occurred in sullivan
county village of liberty
and this was let's see christopher
peckney 28 he died in the blast his
brother was injured
and this was not actually at the gender
reveal party they were they were
building the prop
testing it so that they could then bring
it to the gender reveal party and this
tragic accident occurred
this i think is the second gender reveal
death in the last couple of weeks
and those two are not the only i mean
this is something that we
see every spring basically it seems to
be a seasonal thing every spring and
summer
we see these stories um gender reveal
canons gender reveal
pyrotechnics and uh everything
fireworks going off people dying forest
fires being set
when are we going to get to a point
where we're done with this
i'm not necessarily asking for the
government to step in and ban gender
reveal parties
uh i don't think we're quite at that
point but as a society i think we should
be ready to move on from gender reveal
parties um really
one person dying because of a gender
reveal party is way too much
that is a cost not worth paying but when
you've got
multiple deaths and forest fires
starting every year because of gender
reveal parties
come on and what it comes down to is is
you have to keep in mind if you're
if you're thinking of staging a gender
reveal party and even if you're not
involving any pyrotechnics which
hopefully you aren't
nobody really cares about the gender of
your child
your friends and family they care about
the fact they're having a baby that's a
wonderful thing
but they don't have a preference for
what gender it is
they don't really care that much so this
idea of
dramatically revealing the gender and
then
everyone has to be excited either way
so it's it seems like the most useless
sort of uh pageantry
save all the celebration for the birth
and and all that kind of stuff it's
exciting to have a baby
congratulations but um i don't think the
gender reveal parties are
have much point to them five finally
cancun gates
the lamest political scandal of the
modern era has not gone away just yet
some activists uh showed up outside of
ted cruz's house to play
mariachi music as a way of trolling him
for going to
cancun for less than 24 hours let's
listen to a little bit of that here it
[Laughter]
[Music]
is okay a couple things about the
mariachi music so they're standing
around playing mariachi music outside of
ted cruz's house
just two quick points number one
mariachi music every time i hear it i am
shocked anew
by how terrible it is it is the worst
genre of music i'm sorry but it simply
is
i can't tell you how many uh nice
dinners at mexican restaurants have been
ruined
because of mariachi music it is really
really bad music it's simply
it's like polka music level it's it's on
it's
it's that tier of the dregs of of
music genres that's the first thing
which which actually makes it i guess
effective trolling because it's so
terrible
um and the second thing is if
if you're worried that ted cruz is not
contributing enough not helping out
enough with
um you know getting texas back and
running
after the after the disaster last week
if you're worried about that
then maybe you should be chipping in and
going to volunteer somewhere
instead of standing around ted cruz's
house playing mariachi music
see your your word ted cruz isn't doing
anything you're standing outside of his
house
either holding a sign or playing
terrible music
so get your own house in order stop
throwing stones when you're living in
that glass house
with the terrible music all right let's
go to our comments now we go to our uh
most recent beloved segment reading the
youtube comments this is from
user name the q a he says a better name
for these
new puritans would be impuritins
we discussed yesterday the left is there
are the new puritans in puritans i like
that
and i will steal it and i'll tell you
right now i'm not going to give you
credit
uh this is from username i like i look
like the word lacrosse
that's the username walsh i have to
admit i tried out your burrito recipe
and it was actually pretty good
well thanks for trying it out and and
all right well i guess really you should
be thanking me because i'm the one who
gave you that delicious recipe if you
haven't seen my burrito recipe
you can go to instagram or on youtube my
youtube channel and find um
i did kind of a there was a viral
burrito recipe and i did my own version
of it
and i i think rave reviews from everyone
who's tried it so you should go check
that out john kirkwood writes the
original puritans wouldn't celebrate
christmas either
the puritans feared that somewhere
someone was having fun
you nailed it matt well i think that's
probably gross
simplification of the puritans and what
they believed i i believe it's true that
they didn't celebrate christmas but
actually the word puritan
me comes from purified they were trying
to purify what were they trying to
purify
what they were primarily wanting to
purify is um
christianity of catholicism they were
very anti-catholic
and they wanted to purify uh
catholic influence in christianity
so that's where the name comes from and
being anti-catholic i guess that's
another thing they have in common with
the modern left in fact
this is from gull wings he writes our
whole lives we have appropriated
literally everything that's ever existed
that's how we survived this generation
didn't discover
fire farming cars you can name you can
name anything
really we've been creating and improving
on past creations and inventions
if you have a better tequila recipe then
by all means appropriate it and improve
it and sell it
we all win when we are when we uh when
there are more choices in the market
this is all absolutely absurd um
it is that's very well stated these are
all things this is how
society this is how cultures develop
society
evolves through
influencing each other you know there
was a time
long ago it seems now when the claim was
that we
you know we wanted america to be a
melting pot and so all different
cultures would come here and
and we would assimilate and influence
each other and it would be one big happy
family
um that was the claim and in fact people
that were
advocates for immigration so like
the left wingers of 30 years ago that's
what they said
you'll notice though they don't talk
about the melting pot anymore they don't
want a melting pot
no they want people to come here and
then set up their own
segregated communities with no influence
from the outside world
so if there is no one unified coherent
america that's their goal
and they're succeeding finally dave says
come on matt you can't hide from me
forever as a fellow banjo player i have
to hear you play the banjo just so i can
find out how pathetically inferior
your banjo skills are to mine if you
continue to ignore me you will be
canceled
well first of all i've played the banjo
before on on the air
i'm not going to be goaded to playing it
again first of all i'm not a trained
monkey here to amuse you
i mean i am here to amuse you and some
would say that i'm basically a trained
monkey but still
that's not the point second of all i
play the banjo every day all right
all day in my heart the banjo music of
my heart that's what matters
the most third of all you are a disgrace
and a scoundrel
and you're banned from the show you know
one thing we desperately need in our
country and our culture today are
companies out there that are working for
us
in the culture not against us and that's
why i'm so grateful for 40 days
for life um the state of our culture
frustrates all of us we have politicians
lobbying for infanticide
and and we have you know far left we
know all of that going on
but you know where i see real progress
is at the grassroots level
in 40 days for life and i've talked
about this many times this is the fact
that we have to we have to focus on the
most localized level possible
work in our own communities try to get a
handle on that we can't
we have no hope of making any changes on
a national scale
if we can't make changes on a local
scale first 40 days for life that's what
they're all about 40 days for life went
from
one peaceful prayer vigil in the front
of a planned parenthood in texas to now
a thousand cities
in 66 countries 40 days of prayer
fasting and law abiding vigils have
saved 18 000 babies from abortion
they're saving lives they're making a
real difference they've helped 211
abortion workers leave their jobs
they've closed 107 abortion facilities
including
the texas location that now serves as
the headquarters for 40 days for life so
they shut down an abortion facility
and they took it over and uh they turned
it into
a headquarters to fight for life which
is just awesome you can be a part of the
beginning of the end of abortion by
joining one million volunteers and sign
up for your location at
40daysforlife.com
you can also stay updated on the number
one pro-life podcast 40 days for life
the largest spring campaign ever is
happening from february 17th
through march 28th so it's going on
right now got to get involved
um i have you know been a been a big
supporter and fan of 40 days for life
for a long time
i can vouch for this organization and
you want to be a part too so don't wait
for washington to heal our culture go to
work in our neighborhood
at 40daysforlife.com
also join us tomorrow february 24th for
this month's
backstage you know we entered 2021 with
our debut into the world of
entertainment and we've kept the big
news coming it's pretty
pretty busy already it's only the the
year is less than two months old
most recently we announced our movie
deal with gina carano we'll be uh
talking about current events and all of
our daily wire highlights of the month
and as always we'll be taking questions
from our members at this
at this uh week's backstage so make sure
you go to dailywire.com
subscribe and join us before backstage
starts so you can ask questions
and maybe get on air with your question
we'll also be talking about ben
shapiro's new series debunked
there are so many narratives around hot
topic issues it's hard to keep track of
all the newest controversies that the
left decides to get offended by
which is why you're going to want to
tune in to debunked to see ben
expose leftist fallacies in 15 minutes
or less climate change universal health
care covert policies
all of that versus facts and logic ben's
new show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members so if you aren't
already a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25
off the reasons to join daily wire keep
piling up so use code debunked
for 25 off today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
so today we're going to cancel the la
times for this article from noah
biermann titled
black female and high profile kamela
harris is a top
target in online fever swaps the
article's meant to perpetuate the myth
that left-wing women especially
left-wing
non-white women are special victims of
abuse and harassment online of course
there's no doubt that they are targeted
for abuse and harassment online
everyone is the more high profile you
are the more of a target you become
nobody doubts this but the claim is that
women of color to use the momentarily
preferred pc moniker
are more often victims of this kind of
treatment than anyone else
the reasons that the media is so
determined to push this narrative i
think are pretty obvious for one thing
if if if left-wing minority women are
most often victimized by online
harassment
that would mean that white right-wing
males presumably are most often the ones
committing online harassment
of course in reality women harass each
other way more often
than men harass women but we're talking
about the media narrative here and what
they want us to believe
the media is eager for any opportunity
to cast their most despised group
in the villain role so that's one thing
for another thing this is all part of
the ongoing effort by the media and the
democrat party to push
social media to and the social media
platforms to ramp up their censorship
and that's made clear at the very start
in the article it says quote
soon after joe biden announced last year
that he would pick a woman as his
running mate
democratic congresswoman jackie speier
began warning facebook executives
female politicians received the most
vile online attacks
the company's filters were falling
failing to stop them
spyer said we showed them 20 examples
that were disgusting
and they were still up she was talking
about a meeting
with chief operating officer sheryl
sandberg at facebook facebook's response
gave her a little comfort
keep sending us these horrific examples
she said executives told her
and we'll take them down spire's
concerns that the first female vice
president would
would attract outsized assaults and
venomous lies from social media's
ugliest players
have now been validated research shows
that camilla harris may be the most
targeted american politician on the
internet
one who checks every box for the haters
of the fever swamps she's a woman she's
a person of color
and she holds power okay now already we
know that this
cannot be true the idea that camilla
harris
attracts more venom than donald trump is
absurd on its face
there cannot possibly be a more targeted
american politician
on the internet than donald trump the
only way they could justify this claim
is if they hinge it on the technicality
that donald trump is out of office at
the moment so he's he isn't technically
a politician
but even putting trump aside is camila
harris more targeted than say
ted cruz and what do we mean by targeted
what counts as abuse and harassment what
is meant by
venomous lies well let's keep reading
it says quote abuse directed at women is
highly personalized
often attacking them based on their
appearance and denigrating their
intelligence
said cecile goran a researcher in london
at the institute for strategic dialogue
a think tank that sinks to
that seeks to counter extremism
disinformation and polarization
she said it's also more likely to imply
that they should quit politics and that
they don't belong in the public space
oh abuse directed at women is highly
personalized you say
yes as opposed to abuse directed at men
which we all know is not personal at all
it wasn't personal when trump was called
fat and ugly approximately 7 million
times a day on the internet
7 million by my account anyway and my
accounting method isn't any less
scientific than whatever method they're
using
there are currently hundreds of memes
comparing mitch mcconnell to a turtle
that's an attack based on appearance
it's also kind of true but that's beside
the point
and the claim that women are uniquely
insulted based on their intelligence is
well the kind of claim that only a
person of low intelligence could believe
woman or man more from the article says
goran led a recent study that did not
include harris but showed that american
female politicians were two to three
times more likely to receive abusive
twitter comments than male counterparts
such findings elevate widespread
concerns that women still significantly
underrepresented in political and
corporate offices
will avoid or give up leadership jobs
that leave them vulnerable to online
abuse
it certainly discourages women from
getting engaged in politics speyer said
given worries about family and personal
safety
okay a study
well here we go it should be clear to
you now that it should be clear to you
by now that whenever a study
is referenced in a mainstream media
article the person making the reference
is counting on you not
actually reading the study that's the
great thing about studies
many people seem to think that that a
point can be proven simply by saying the
word study
the the word study is enough this is
what passes for an argument nowadays
oh yeah you don't believe me well a
study says i'm right
oh a study well if the study says it
then never mind
i happen to be one of those annoying
people who actually wants to read the
study
see when you tell me about a study i'm
going to say i want to see it show me
this study i'm going to read it myself
and in reading studies i have found and
i have no studies to prove this i admit
but i found that most studies are to put
this scientifically
bull crap keep in mind that you can call
anything a study there's no required
standard methodology for a study
that's why reading the study itself is
so important so let me let me read a bit
of this study to you
the title of the study is public figures
public rage
candidate abuse candidate abuse on
social media that's the title
skipping ahead to page 12 it says
we analyzed the language most often used
to target candidates over the 11 day
period of study and extracted a list of
surprising keywords and phrases for each
individual in a three-step process
one we obtained 20 keywords by
contrasting the data from tweets to a
sample of standard english wikipedia
data
helping identify uncommon vocabulary two
we extracted 20 keywords by contrasting
the individual of interest twitter data
with that of other candidates to
identify language
specifically targeting that person three
we filtered these 40 keywords out
through a blacklist likely to generate
background noise for this research we
blacklisted the terms trump covid
the individual's name and common aliases
political party names and common state
names
we ordered key words and phrases by
their degree of unexpectedness
and selected the top 20. now
what what does any of that mean degree
of unexpectedness
how the hell do you measure that i mean
doesn't this whole process sound
extremely arbitrary and subjective
they're also only taking into account
public comments made to these figures in
my experience
by far the worst abuse comes through
email and private message
any study of online abuse that doesn't
factor private messages is pretty
worthless it would seem
it's like measuring the amount of
bullying in school but not counting gym
class or the cafeteria
those are like the bullying factories
you can't you can't take that out of it
at any rate on the next page is a table
listing keywords and phrases used to
target candidates here are some of the
key words and phrases for ilhan omar
shameful defund the police
and somalia wow how abusive
now for nancy pelosi hypocrites
unverified
antifa yes apparently to call out a
woman's hypocrisy
or to say that her claims are unverified
is abusive now
the study then gives real world examples
of abusive comments made to nancy pelosi
so here's one this is a
there's an actual abusive comment that
the study shows and this shows us what
they consider to be abusive
so somebody some abusive scoundrel said
to nancy pelosi
she's not doing a very good job better
get on that nan
here's one to ilhan omar she's an
anti-american
she's as anti-american and
anti-constitutional as they come
this is a republican or a public not a
democracy
if she doesn't understand that she'll
never understand the constitution or the
bill of rights
that's the abuse but no this is not
abuse this is not harassment this is
called
criticism she's not doing a good job
is a very civilized very understated
very polite way of criticizing a
politician who in fact is not doing a
good job
the comment about ilhan amar is also a
criticism and also well deserved
but this is what the study which spawned
the la times article categorizes as
vile anti-woman misogynistic abuse
do you want to know what an actual
abusive comment sounds like
i'll give you one here it is i know what
city you in
white you think you can keep talking
behind your phone in tweets i'll smoke
you
stupid ass take care of your ugly white
daughter
that was a message sent to me recently
threatening to hunt me down and murder
me along with my seven-year-old daughter
that checks all the boxes doesn't it
racist insulting explicitly threatening
if you want a more recent example here's
one that came to my inbox just this
morning
i went online first thing as i always do
had my cup of coffee
and uh you know starting the day it had
the pleasure of reading this
f you i hope you die like the rest of
your pathetic ilk you support
now pretty tame compared to a lot of the
stuff i get but even so wishing death on
me
i've received literally thousands of
messages emails and comments like this
thousands
threatening death wishing death
threatening harm against my children
wishing harm against my children
comments merely mocking my appearance
are so utterly banal at this point that
i don't even notice them
if i do notice them i'm tempted to send
a message back
thanking the person because at least
they didn't promise to burn down my
house with my family trapped inside
compared to that kind of feedback
calling me ugly seems downright polite
now do i receive more than my fair share
of this kind of vitriol
i don't know probably not i have no way
of knowing
what i do know is that being a white
male with a platform on the internet
does not in
any way protect you from quote abuse
i can tell you that from experience
trust me now the unfortunate thing is
that the insistence on focusing on the
gender and racial components of this
issue
the effort to fit online harassment and
abuse into the standard mainstream
victimhood narrative
prevents us from having what could
otherwise be a valuable and necessary
conversation
no women are not specially targeted
black people are not
specially targeted but they are targeted
everybody is
and though many of the examples provided
in the study are pretty trite
i have no doubt that you know the people
that are mentioning the study
receive plenty of these sort of i hope
you die go kill yourself type comments
just as i do
we're used to people saying that kind of
stuff on the internet
i'm used to people telling me that they
hope my family dies painfully
because they disagree with my political
opinions i'm used to it we're used to it
but we shouldn't be i mean it does say
something quite disturbing about
humanity
that this is how we treat each other
when we have the cloak of anonymity to
protect us
that's a conversation i would really
like to have that's a conversation we
should be having
because there are a lot of people who
want to dismiss all of this and say oh
it's just the internet it doesn't count
no it's not just the internet these are
people
the person who threatened to kill my
seven-year-old daughter because he
doesn't he doesn't agree with my
opinions
that's an actual person now
he's not actually going to do it i'm not
going to assume he's not going to do it
i did we did contact the police and we
reported it because you make a threat
against my family that's what's going to
happen every time
but i'm not i don't actually think he's
going to do it
thousands of messages of this sort
nobody they don't really do it but
but these are these are people though
behind these messages
actual people talking to other actual
people
the fact that they'll only speak this
way on the internet
you know that that doesn't make it
better that only makes it worse
because what it tells you that is that
on top of being vile scumbags these are
also cowards
you know you tell someone to kill
themselves because you disagree with
their opinion
you would never say that to their face
but that's because you're a coward
the fact that you would say it at all
still makes you a vile disgusting
dirtbag
and what we've discovered from the
internet which is maybe no big surprise
there are a lot
a lot of cowardly vile disgusting dirt
bags out there
they're not they're not unique to one
side or the other
but they're a lot of them that is a
conversation i would like to have we
should be having that conversation
not to push for censorship or anything
like that but just to say what the hell
is going on
with humanity right now but we can't
have it
because it always has to go down to race
and gender and the standard victim of
narratives
and that's why the la times is canceled
and that'll do it for me today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. merrick
garland comes back from the political
grave
dr fauci wants masks through 2022 and
cpac cancels a bigot check it out on the
michael knowles show